c'est un thème qui vous tient
particulièrement à coeur également
particulièrement à coeur et je peux pas
éviter de faire le lien avec la question
qui est posée ce soir eric par rapport à
ce que hakan martin où nous a dit le
lien je le ferai en imaginant
dramatiquement et en pensant aux
souffrances de ceux qui par un
confinement obligé se retrouve enfermé
dans un contexte de violence
le bafouement des valeurs les plus
élémentaires d'humiliation de torture
parfois de sévices et je me dis que le
confinement s'il faut l'éviter c'est
aussi et surtout pour ceux là mêmes dont
je pense à ses enfants je pense aux
femmes battues
on sait qu'il ya 65 % de recrudescence
de femmes battues jetten il viendra ce
soir
mais là on parle des enfants et moi
c'est vrai que cette cause des enfants
maltraités et abusés et il ya un fait
d'actualité malheureusement qui a ramené
sa donc au coeur de l'actualité avec la
fille de bernard kouchner qui a écrit un
ouvrage et qui a expliqué comment son
frère jumeau était abusée par son beau
père je trouve que notre société
elle n'est pas assez vigilante sur ces
sujets et je vais même plus loin c'est
pas provocateur ce que je vais y aller
une forme de tolérance nous tolérance
une forme d'intelligence ya une forme
d'élite 2 que qui se permet des choses
qui sont inacceptables qui sont
inhumaines qui sont scandaleuses
lamentable dans un contexte d' impunité
de connivence de complicité mois ci un
combat j'en ai mené beaucoup dans ma vie
contre les discriminations entre que
j'aurais envie de mener au cours des des
années futures
c'est ce combat pour ces enfants là
parce que je considère que à un moment
donné libérer la parole
c'est aussi les libérer c'est aussi
faire en sorte qu'ils ne soient pas sous
le joug je dirais de l'adulte qui qui
les abusent d'adultes ans qu'il devrait
avoir confiance
l'adulte qui devrait leur donner la
confiance et l'amour
ambiance la tension est on s'en rend
même pas compte quand on est né avec
tout ça quand on est des grands mères
des tentes des oncles des parents qui
vous donne l'amour qui vous donne la
confiance qui vous regarde avec avec les
yeux de la bienveillance les dieux de la
protection quand on a des enfants qui
subissent ça on se rendent pas compte
je dirais le le fardeau qu'ils ont et je
crois que notre société se mobilise pas
assez il faut que nous soyons beaucoup
plus dure sur le plan judiciaire il faut
que nous libérions la parole il faut que
nous soyons intransigeant sans pitié
face à ces intellectuels qui viennent
sur les plateaux télé nous expliquer
qu'ils ont touché des gamins donc de 12
1 de 13,1 de 14 ans et que c'était pas
si grave
c'est une autre société à l' intérêt à
avoir plus de sévérité contre ceux là et
faire en sorte que nous puissions nous
mobiliser tous et ce témoignage là que
ce soir m'amène à dire le confinement
non pour cela parce que ce sont des
souffrances invisible silencieuse
dramatique je rappelle que dernière
émission de l'année oui de l'année
dernière nous avions reçu 4 0 qui mène
un combat exactement 13 exemplaires et
voilà sapin sur cinq un enfant européen
sur cinq serait victime de sévices donc
je renvoie vers le jeu remarquable
travail 0 mais avec un parti est-ce que
s'il avait eu un confinement à l'époque
où vous étiez ce gamin mal traités quel
aurait été votre sort serait encore pire
non j'avoue apparemment vous parlais
tout à l'heure de l'école quand même
comme comme une soupape comme une
liberté que j'avais tort comme le oui
comme d'une évasion raison bah je pense
que ça aurait été très difficile
et là je vais je vais faire un transfert
par rapport à aujourd'hui comment je
vois les choses en tant que personne
lambda et en tant que professionnel
là où je suis inquiet s'il ya un
troisième confinement c'est que les
familles qui vont qui ont déjà des
difficultés vont se retrouver isolé et
donc sans accompagnement de travailleurs
sociaux ou même ceux qui n'ont pas vos
produire des schémas de violences qui
ont déjà pu se passer au premier
confinement on l'a vu il ya énormément
de situations qui ont explosé et le 119
a eu énormément d'appels sur le premier
confinement aujourd'hui moi je vois pour
lui rappeler ses numéros de téléphone
ouais c'est ça change 1919 c'est ça
nîmes
oui on peut parler vraiment sans avoir
peur à ce numéro de téléphone c'est à
dire que si on confine et qu'on ferme
les écoles les collèges donc les enfants
qui ont une possibilité d'exprimer
quelque chose où justement de sortir de
ce quotidien ne pourront plus s'exprimer
toutes les associations sportives qui
s'arrêtent barre du coup ses éducateurs
qui sont présents pour eux ils seront
plus là pour ses enfants et donc on va
avoir des situations qui vont être de
plus en plus catastrophique en terme de
structure qui accueille sur des
internats on l'a vu sur le premier
confinement on a eu énormément de
travailleurs sociaux qui ont été en
arrêt qui n'ont pas pu travailler donc
ça a été aussi une non préparation des
politiques sociales par rapport à cette
situation ils ont mis énormément de
temps à mettre des choses en place et
c'est des associations ou alors des
bénévoles ou des gens qui justement
milite pour la protection enfance qui
ont proposé des choses sur les réseaux
sociaux pour essayer de faire avancer
les choses
donc je suis assez inquiet et là dans
mon travail aujourd'hui je suis
éducateur spécialisé en mmo c'est action
éducative en milieu ouvert donc on
travaille directement chez les familles
qui nous il ya une notion danger et on
peut voir sur juste sur notre structure
où on a énormément de situations en
attente et des situations qui date de
l'année dernière donc c'est à dire que
depuis l'année dernière on laisse des
enfants qui ont été justement en
situation de danger où il ya eu des
appels qui ont été faits et on peut pas
se saisir de ces problèmes étaient car
moi j'ai trente mineurs à ma charge
tout comme mon équipe qui travaille
vraiment bien d'ailleurs je leur passe
un petit coucou
mais on n'a pas assez de moyens pour
assumer tout ça est haut et c'est ce qui
m'inquiète parce que on a des
travailleurs sociaux qui sont essoufflés
on a un métier qui n'est pas c'est
reconnu malheureusement qui est sous
payé et on a des politiques sociales qui
aujourd'hui font de la com